hello I the Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't have to well it finally
happened I've been traumatized by the
movie I just saw a film so bad that my
doctor tells me I may never speak again
what film brought me to such a
speechless state well let me tell you
the story of a sauerkraut named you evil
he is being declared the new Edward of
the film world a man who constantly
keeps making horrible movie after
horrible movie and yet somehow keeps
making money he mostly makes videogame
films like also the dead and blood ring
his gimmick is that he exercises German
tax loopholes that reward his
investments into the film even if they
totally um so if the movie loses money
the investor got a tax write-off he's
also well-known for challenging his
critics to a boxing match and beating
the living men shit out of them class
act because of his unfortunate
popularity many of my viewers have been
requesting me to review one of his
movies I took a look at one of his more
famous films along in the dark and I'm
now paying the consequences
I'd love to review the movie for you but
I do not want to sound like Stephen
Hawking speaking coach so it looks like
I'm going to pass on this one unless I
can find someone to raise someone's I
love all man I wanted to take a shot at
that cinematic Hitler for years how did
you get in here I'm from the future what
I'm just kidding I broken well not that
I wouldn't want to watch the movie again
with you spoony but I fear a fill this
bed would take at least three reviewers
so unless you can find some real guys oh
Jesus
no I saw the Nostalgia signal on the sky
why did I install that no one should
have to watch you've a ball alone
especially with spooning hey dude
check out what I can make the Nostalgia
Critic say I like to wear women's
clothing I like to wear women's clothing
well I guess we have enough people to
withstand the horrors of the whole so
what do you say we watch alone in the
dark with a group in the daylight sounds
very totally looking forward to it good
[Music]
so we start off with an opening text for
all explaining the background of the
story mine workers discovered the first
remnants of a long-lost Native American
civilization the abkani the akane
believed there are two worlds on this
planet the world of light in a world of
darkness
if connie were kind of stupid that way
the abkani opened a gate between these
worlds the abkani mysteriously vanished
from the earth they never think to look
under the fridge only a few artifacts
remained hidden in the worlds oh god how
long is this like alone in the dark the
audio of oxygens Bureau 713 began
collecting abkani artifacts when the
government ah how much text is in this
movie this isn't a bill for health care
let's get to the friggin action already
there he conducted savage experiments on
orphaned jabal ringing the scible ring
this is a whole range into the show
survive as sleepers lost souls awaiting
the moment of their calling wait I
missed something could you start it
again no any more of that no so I guess
22 years before that onslaught of
rambling text there was a sweet innocent
old nun who ran a lovely little
orphanage where she sold her children to
the most adorable science experiments
wait what the children are my
responsibility we've been through this
before these children have been
specially selected it's not about a few
children it's about the future of our
species
well James Lipton had found a way to
have become even ham here so one of the
kids escaped from the evil experiments
and hides in the safest place you can
think of a high-voltage electricity box
but it's okay he sand by a flash forward
to the future oh no he grew up into
Christian Slater did you have a
nightmare my mommy says that there's
nothing to be afraid of in the dark
my mummy also says I should pick an
accent before I act
this is Edward our main character who
makes us living as a professional
monologue er my name is edward carnby
and I'm here to protect you from the
things you don't believe you see there's
a world around you that you trained
yourself not to see so maybe you're
thinking I'm an asshole scaring that kid
for no reason no we think you're an
asshole for a lot of other reasons when
I was 10 I lost my memory gone erased
you don't have to believe me
why sir now what do you do I'm a
paranormal investigator I hunt and track
down the strange and unusual
I think his performance in the Whizzer
is an upgrade compared to this Casbah
fallen as if you left the airport one
elusive mind
be careful Jesse Ventura been known to
kill people so they have themselves a
little car chase until defense to reduce
nails them in a corner
Slater tells a cab driver not to move so
long rare white cab driver guy you know
for protecting us from the things we
don't believe in he really sucks at it
so rather than just attacking the guy he
climbs up a fence walks over a bridge
and then attacks the guy I guess he
figured he could use the exercise you
don't have to beat up the door pal you
could have just as easily gone through
the window you smash through carries
thrashing through another window what is
with this guy does fear of doors to the
door kill his family physically
impossible street fighter move like boom
nobody can levitate a kick like that
from off the ground unless of course the
man was Jonas
so Slater tries to shoot the guy but it
turned out bullets are just like milk
guns being thrown at him
yes because it works so well the first
time
[Music]
so wait a minute knocking him senseless
does nothing
shooting him does nothing but falling on
a sharp pointy stick that just happens
to be laying around on the ground is
what kills him that makes no sense
unless of course that man was Chuck
Norris daddy makes no sense so we could
to a scientist named Aileen played by
Tara Reid how do we know she's a
scientist well because she has glasses
of course and as we all know any woman
who has glasses is either a scientist or
an adventurous librarian as if wearing
glasses makes you look any smarter I
need glasses it's probably for the big
I'll kind of show up honey what the
hell's up honey
it's an ancient Native American
civilization okay yeah don't you know
like everyone knows about the abkani
tribe it was all over MTV News last week
for sure so we see Slater trying to walk
away from the plot when he has a sudden
suspicion like he's being followed and
he's not huh you know from the way they
were shooting I got a sworn he was being
followed nope he is just walking home
with no conflicting obstacles whatsoever
huh kind of pointless really yeah so it
turns out a paranormal agent makes
pretty good money as he lives in what
looks like a mix between a garage and a
furniture showroom so he looks at his
archeological decoder ring to see if he
can find any clues as to what it
translates out to
bitch we then cut to a ship in the
middle of the sea where professor Lionel
Hudgens and Gordon fisherman here make
an incredible discovery
a fox made out of 100% pure gold
whatever's inside must be worth a
fortune
I have no idea but fast with you can say
hands off me bow to you the sailors
locked the professor in another room and
try to steal the box away opening it up
and releasing a horrible creature oh no
my acting is going Shatner for some
reason everyone decides to just walk off
the movie I mean jeez I knew the ball
was a horrible director but to have all
the actors just walk off the movie at
the same time that's pretty bad so the
professor opens up the door that was
just locked a second ago to find that
the entire crew has been murdered this
gets the attention of the agency of
paranormal investigations Bureau 713
filled with the most attractive people
the GQ can afford there's no malfunction
soon
Jesus Christ hey look it's that guy who
consistently almost has a career Stephen
Dorff yes
so Slater makes his way back to his old
orphanage in the hopes of figuring out
the secrets to his past and the fact
that some of his old friends are
disappearing it's happening again I need
your help
I want to find the others I'll get their
files so let's go back the way we just
came blocking at its best folks I was
recruited in the Bureau civilize we're
back here this movie jumps around more
than a Mexican jumping bean and a
grasshopper on a jackrabbit on a pogo
stick this movie sucks so he talks with
an old pal to figure out if there's
anything all the people have been
disappearing recently have in common are
you track down the three ask me about
even though you are going in for you
moron nothing much in common except they
all grew up in the same orphanage oh is
that all
just the same orphanage that's like
saying oh they have nothing in common
except for like that one huge thing they
have in common so because this movie
can't sit still for two seconds he goes
to yet another location the museum where
that archeological hottie works
Edward thought you were dead you asshole
we loves Edward if Leigh loves him so
much oh we hate Seth were that we hate
sin with all our and I'm not seriously
critic it just doesn't work unless you
actually have the golem voice my
precious oh no honey it's okay just just
call it off so Elaine analyzes the
artifact and comes up with some baffling
conclusions the thing is they're all
from different locations
Venezuela Newfoundland Alaska and now
this one from Chile burying them at the
ends of the earth
yeah but why if you want someone to
build a puzzle why would you hide the
pieces so far apart because the puzzle
you dummy it supposed to be hard to
solve things look bad when suddenly the
lights in the museum start flickering on
and off and it probably doesn't help the
security guard has just two days left
before retirement yeah flickering lights
zoomable is actually trying to scare us
with flickering light all that's missing
is a guy in a microphone trying to make
scary sound effects
maybe remember me as a brilliant
security guard so Edward and aliens see
the beast and try their best to get away
from oh yeah and trap yourself inside
the building don't run out of the
building or into the streets where
someone could help you this is much more
sensible but thankfully Stephen Dorff
and friends coming to try and save the
day and of course being ignorant jackass
as well got a little soft since you left
713 why you still here I just got my ass
chased around this goddamn museum by
something I couldn't see I wonder what
713 knows about 713 anything okay that
information is classified
that means it's none of your fucking
business what about the business of that
little girl we've got this under control
you're right Burke maybe I have gotten
soft
just keep walking is he trying to out
Slater Christian Slater so Edward goes
to the old doctor friend he saw earlier
to see if he discovered anything about
the Jesse Ventura guy and that was he
trying to kill me this might have
something to do with it never seen this
kind of symbiosis before this must be
why his entire nervous system was
compromised
if by compromised you mean invincible
scanners still giving a rating
what well it appears you have one too oh
we got a cutscene I'll tell you later
they so we see the professor guy
apparently has been keeping some of
these monsters for himself taking their
blood and injecting it into his own what
does this have to do with a story
nothing fool hole is just a weird fuck
oh that's good MacGuffin the man who
attacked me ashamed shut up
Lord he can monologue about anything I
was on my way to get my prostate checked
I suddenly realized I forgot to TiVo la
why the hell was I in Star Trek 6 but
his monologuing doesn't last long as
he's interrupted by a lien dropping by
his place perhaps she's come to share
some info or figure out why he lied
about being dead or maybe she's just a
whore I mean what kind of woman acts
like this breaks into your home and
starts making out with you granted I
wish more women acted like that but this
is really pushing it maybe she left her
keys inside his melton can only get it
out with her tongue in fact how come
there's no narration here don't you
think this would be an interesting spot
to have a monologue I couldn't believe
this chick I mean she does broke into my
home and started doing maybe it's that
new Axe body spray or the fact that I
started bathing again why the hell was I
in Star Trek 6 seems all the pieces fit
together oh is that what you call what
we just did I mean I slapped you after
we hug you don't even want to know what
I'm gonna do after we have sex
cha-cha-cha
uh movie balls turning the light switch
on and off again which must mean there's
danger nearby stay there I'll bravely
abandon you so you can fend for yourself
so there approached by more people with
compromised nervous systems but luckily
their magic glowing bullets hurt them
now
how many more are there Oh trick the
whole sightsee is shot in the dark so
you can't see the action
luckily Norseman the king's bra again to
save the day how do they even know these
guys are evil they could have been
innocent civilians who just wandered in
with all these flashing monocle
I brought science deeper than every
Hey what he didn't even hit her I mean
look at it that goes right above her
head was the shock that somebody was
trying to kill her just too much for her
to handle actually think about it
that gunshot was computer-generated so
the director actually had to say in
post-production make sure that shot
doesn't hit her what a cocksucking
douche bag it's like he's taunting us
without bad he is like he can post
anything he wants and yet somehow he'll
still say rich holy in America and yet
ironically with a German what the hell
is going on here I got a feeling this is
just the beginning oh I love in this
movie this movie has a talent for
somehow having too much plot and yet no
plot at all that's funny man so they put
together that all the nasty monsters and
zombie people are coming from this one
cave or mine or something so they load
up and get ready to go snooping around
wait for my command we've got three
rulers a flashlight set up down the guts
into electromagnetic motion tracking an
every available agent who the suit is
Shiva Collette I don't care what you
have to do I love just random yelling
look at this place we need more I gotta
have my cowbell sell everybody suits up
and guards the cave to make sure no
monsters are zombie folk and break-in
and it's probably a bad thing to mention
that every single one of these soldiers
has just two days left before retirement
so about the next ten minutes of film is
pretty much just our heroes roaming
through Big Thunder Mountain here
finding padding padding padding padding
padding padding padding padding hey look
a wall that's different
hello see that's what happens when you
go up against sub-zero so as you'd
imagine a bunch more to those eight R
Giger droppings up attack the soldiers
but that doesn't stop our heroes from
still snooping around I don't think
we're supposed to be here
you're an idiot what John lay down later
relax everything's gonna be fine well
she's a goner uh shoot it shoot it try
shooting it guys yeah she's dead now
thanks a lot Bureau 713 s finest you
guys check this up it's a warning it
says once you make it down here alive
you already dead but if you come down
here dead you'll become a line even if
you're half dead and half alive then you
might have a better chance of getting
fixed up again first Ashley address
[Applause]
right now our discovers leads never stop
come on let's move hey wait a minute you
told in her head up but play that again
Oh what is with that how do you get away
with that I guess Stephen Dorff was
right she really would be okay nobody
associated with this movie is okay so
the GI schmoes worked their way into a
dark laboratory where they make an
astonishing discovery
[Music]
7:13 implanted us for those things we've
been trying to stop something they
created the whole time my guys are dying
out there for nothing for fucking
nothing
god damn it oh you got you that I'm
acting I like to wear women's clothing I
like to wear now it says if you made it
to this door you weren't intimidated by
the other door I just have been looking
for my whole life to be on the other
side of this thing some doors are meant
to stay shut
yeah like the DVD case to this movie I
spent 20 years looking for the key for
that door
does this place bring back memories
Carly you or - failure yeah if you
hadn't escaped seven-thirty would never
shut down my experiments and I would
have gotten away with it too of it has
been for you pesky kids
rot row oh and that mangy dog doopy
doopy you so Dorf does a perfect
underhanded throw to the guy's chest
so then they open the door and find that
all sorts of monsters they're ready to
meet the world they decide the only
logical thing to do is what all people
with explosives do explode things so
Dorf sacrifices himself don't ask he
just us as edward and Aileen get out
through a back way that leads
coincidentally back to the orphanage
wait a minute it was night a second ago
now it's day that makes no sense
what do you know haven't you heard of
suspension of disbelief so now with the
monsters blown up everything is fine
right no for it turns out some other
group of monsters that was never
explained or shown to us attacked the
city while they were fighting in the
cave resulting in a complete evacuation
of the entire city all in one night wow
that's a lot to buy movie that is a lot
to buy one night they evacuated the city
in one night holy fuck balls is this
stupid and you know what makes it really
tragic is that everyone in the city had
just two days left he'll retire huh and
on top of that didn't those monsters
just do a dandy cleanup job I mean wow
there's not a speck of debris or drop a
blood on the ground these are the
cleanest of hells demonic minions ever
and just when you thought this movie
couldn't possibly rip off any other
famous horror films tell me what this
reminds you of
watch evil dead much so that was uber
balls alone in the dark how does it fare
up horrible god-awful deplorable see why
this guy is called the next Ed Wood this
stories make no sense there's no
originality the plot holes are just
gigantic and on top of all that there's
nothing to do with the game it was based
on there it's over now leave
oh come on I got all these other
moveable movies we can watch like House
of the Dead hey remember to buy a
revolution of the mass why what about
Dungeon Siege hey hey you leave it alone
well if you wanna watch some hot chicks
like I remember it so you don't have to
[Music]